la vedette de ce festival c'est entre
autes Ursula bien sûr mais c'est aussi
toute cette foule cosmopolite tous ces
fanat du cinéma qui gravitent autour du
festival c'est le cas de ville d'une
originale des planches celle qu'on
appelle Marguerite de France vous avez
déjà tourné dans les films j'ai fait 80
films moi 80 films monsieur vous trouvez
que c'est pas une vie ça une vie
d'artiste j'ai fait tous les films
améric et c'est pour ça que vous venez
au festival américain ben je suis
journaliste aussi et grandatrice d'opéra
parler de comédie musicale également ah
oui mais coméie musicale vous pourriez
m'en écrire une je serais capable de la
chamb tout de suite vous êtes un petit
peu la Bedette du festival ici tout le
monde vous connaîitou il y en a pas
d'autres il y a personne qui me
ressemble personne on on prétend que je
suis une Vette il y a longtemps que vous
suivez toutes ces personnalités du
spectacle 4 4 ans tout au moin ah mais
je les connaissais parce que je les
connaissez tout chantais toujours à
Paris avec les artistes qu'est-ce que
vous apporte ce festival de d'être
congratulé on me dit Madame c'est vous
c'est vous personne ne chante comme vous
mais j'ai pas d'âge j'ai 40 ans c'est
tout